Thanks so yes my name is brush I
growth intelligence we're actually just
three floors up and I'm going to talk to
you today about measuring the digital
economy using big data this is a novice
level talk I think and really it's gonna
be very focused on the application of
what we've done so how we've used python
and data to to to examine the digital
economy in examine what that means so in
terms of what I'm going to talk about
today I'll give you some background into
the problem and what we were actually
trying to set out to achieve then I'll
talk a little bit about our approach how
we use Python and data basically to to
achieve our goals and then I'll talk
about the methodology and results that
we actually achieving incising the
digital economy and I'll explain what
that means in a minute and then I'll
also give you a few examples in terms of
where these businesses can be found and
what it means to be a digital business
so in terms of some background on the
project itself this was a research
project that was supported by Nestor and
Google we worked what great intelligence
we partnered with a some economists from
the national institute of economic and
social research we've been working on
this for about a year now we published a
report last summer which is available
online it's linked from our site and
from knees and site as well and we are
currently underway with some further
faces work so we're still still working
on this project at the moment so these
were the three research questions we set
out to answer so the first one was about
really understanding what it means to be
a digital company what does what does
that mean trying to come up with a
clearer definition the clean definition
of what that is and then actually trying
to count the number of businesses that
fall under that that umbrella the second
question is then trying to kind of dive
more deeply into what would it what it
means to be a digital company and come
up with more descriptive analysis around
around those businesses in terms of
looking at some of the myths I suppose
about about digital businesses so
there's a kind of common conception that
these are startups in Texas
teor that you know their flash in the
pan businesses and not really key to
driving our economic growth but that
mean case that made the big case so it's
really trying to understand what what
drives the growth of these businesses
and the third question is then it's a
the third question is actually really
about trying to understand what drives
the growth of these businesses so what's
behind these digital companies why why
they grow in why they innovate in what
and kind of trying to look at the
causality is so basically sampling the
kind of present-day data looking back at
some historic data in trying to
translate them to what I'm going to talk
about today is really the first question
because that's what we've what the
report last summer was was about so why
are we doing this well the digital
economy is currently quite poorly served
by traditional data sets so trying to
come up with a definition of what is
digital industry the government everyone
tends to rely on standard standard
systems for classification and companies
house data so companies house is is
actually great where the UK is actually
a leader in terms of the availability of
data on businesses but it has its flaws
and one of the main floor has been that
it obviously only includes historic data
in terms of the standard classifications
that are used to describe these
businesses so i should say there are
about 3 million registered companies in
in companies house and includes limited
businesses and public companies and
LLP's so partnerships in terms of how
these classifications or definitions are
used I mean they're pervasive in
industry so credit and risk his
decisions are made using standard
definitions a good example of this where
we're probably rather a bad example of
where this data was used was in 2008 to
the leading credit insurers were
basically stopped underwriting credit
for huge swaths of businesses in
construction but and they basically did
this by sector or by using the standard
way of segmenting the market and the
reason they did this was because it was
you know post credit crunch it was
high-risk construction companies but
really this wasn't looking at the risk
associated with the entity itself it was
simply saying right you're in this
bucket therefore you know we're not
going to provide you with with credit
also government policies obviously
heavily driven by understanding the
economy and especially the the agenda at
the moment around the kind of digital
push and text City and things like that
and also things like you know tax breaks
for computer games companies and all
sorts of policy decisions are made based
on all this kind of data trying to
measure economic productivity you know
we're primarily a services based economy
now I would probably and that's quite
difficult you know in the past
manufacturing you could kind of count
the number of cars coming off a factory
line and you could say yes we're
producing more as a country and
therefore you can have a fairly accurate
measure of economic output I don't claim
to be an economist by the way so feel
free to challenge me on some of this
stuff but clearly there is a challenge
when trying to measure economic output
of services and digital businesses and I
guess the last point which is really i
should say that's that's where own bias
comes in is about trying to understand
businesses who sell to other businesses
use this data trying segment the market
so you can imagine a banker banks SMEs
will perhaps give preferential rates for
you know that and and construction
companies but not preferential banking
rates for you know tree surgeons or
something and so so it's quite important
basically to come up with a good
definition so what am I really talking
about the current definition is that's
used is called standard Industrial
Classification syc codes they were
brought into being in 1948 this was kind
of post-war government wanted to try and
have a clear understanding of what the
makeup of the economy was since nineteen
forty eight they've been revised about
every ten years the latest version is
was brought into being in 2007 and was
adopted by the UK into that
and by companies house in in 2011 there
are about 737 31 different si si codes
so they're extremely detailed but
they're not without their issues and the
key issues are really the way in which
they're generated so when a business
registers at companies house basically
the business chooses themselves at that
point they self classify so they'll say
I fit into this bucket I'm an oil and
gas company but clearly there's no real
incentive for the business to get that
right and there's no incentive for them
to change it if if they change what
they're doing so for example a business
founded founded 30 years ago as a you
know hardware consultancy might be a web
hosting company today but there's no
real reason they would have gone back
and changed their definition but this is
the data that's being used by by
government and everyone the other
problem is actually because there are so
many different codes it's actually quite
hard for you to find the one that you
best fit into and conversely because
it's a system that's only really updated
every 10 years it's quite hard for
emerging sectors to be represented so
for example there aren't really as I see
codes to describe nano tech companies or
fin tech companies or any of the kind of
emerging businesses so this does mean
that it's quite difficult to get a good
gauge as to what what the real makeup of
the economy is so this is just a bit of
bit of fun really but I picked out a few
si si codes that I thought were a bit
more novel so renting of videotapes
chimney sweeping I didn't even know the
UK did raising of channels but there are
about 20 companies that apparently breed
alpacas striking of coins so obviously
the Royal Mint um I guess needs to be
classified dismantling of Rex I didn't
know what the last one meant growing I
don't even know how to say that word
actually but I think it something to do
with coconuts so yeah but the key the
key thing is these last two points here
at the bottom which you might not be
able to see at the bat but basically ten
percent of businesses
are classified as other because they
simply haven't been able to classify
themselves in any other way and twenty
percent of businesses don't have an SI c
code so that's you know about whatever
thirty percent of 3 million is a large
number this is uh this is again just to
illustrate the kind of businesses that
are in these codes so I know word clouds
aren't necessarily the best way to
represent data but I thought it would be
interesting just to look at some of the
businesses in in the other category and
size them by their revenue so these are
the largest turning over businesses so
you've got companies like I TV in there
it's Barry in which ironically provide
credit data symantec DHL think Chelsea
Football Club were in there Johnson
maybe I think is a chemicals company
you've got pharmaceuticals Reuters think
Canary Wharf group might been in there
as well actually but probably probably
best skim over that so basically the
point I'm trying to say is businesses
that are classified as other actually do
a huge variety of different things and
it really doesn't make any sense for us
to be looking at the economy in this way
so so this is a challenge we face the
digital economy isn't straightforward to
define what does it mean to be digital
you know really refers to not only a set
of sectors that businesses may operate
in but also the kind of primary output
those businesses have the kind of
products and services they're producing
and also actually the kind of inputs
they have you could imagine a business
that is wholly reliant on technology for
its processing and its manufacturing or
its its its value add being defined as a
digital business or digitally enabled
business so what this means is is using
a system that the maps directly onto
industries is always going to be in
precise the government actually defines
digital companies has been in those in
ICT or or producing digital content and
those map to a to a series of si si
codes which which I've gotten in
appendix somewhere what we set out to do
basically is therefore to say actually
we think
a data-driven approach will give us a
better a better answer here a better
handle on the digital economy so using
data that's out there will provide
richer more informative and more
up-to-date classification to these
businesses so so how did we do it how do
we do it so we have basically a huge
array of different data sets that are
linked back to businesses so we start
from companies house we take all the
registered businesses in companies house
and then we link a huge number of other
data sets for example news articles
talking about the business patents their
file trademarks they've filed web sites
so things like Wikipedia is well
obviously but company websites
themselves linkedin social media all
that kind of stuff and we build up this
related document set around a business
basically looking at all of the the
words that are written about them and
that they write about themselves and we
do this for all three million companies
in the UK incidentally we also can
combine this with some of our our client
data but to do slightly more novel
things as well so our approach is to
define a different kind of
classification system a
multi-dimensional system so we still
incorporate sectors it makes sense
businesses operating verticals but we
also look at the principal output of
that business so the the product type so
whether that's a service or physical
good they're producing we try and
understand what the type of client they
sell to is so where their business
focused or consumer focused or or public
sector focused and we also try and
understand how they sell to businesses
their route to market so where they sell
through projects or subscriptions or on
a franchise model whatever it may be so
this is just to illustrate why we've
done that you know we think of this as a
kind of if I just look at sectors and
products so I've got sectors across the
top and some example out product types
down the side so the idea is basically
you might be an oil and gas company that
produces software so or you might be a
telecommunications company that would
use software
IT company or you might be you know an
oil and gas company that produces
hardware and then probably you're not
really a digital business but the reason
we can do this is then we can come up
with a more fine finer grained approach
to identifying these businesses so how
do we actually achieve this practically
so we take a very Python orientated
approach we were you know use Python
extensively so we have a series of
crawlers and api's we use scrapy or
scrape I'm never really sure how to say
that which is a Python crawler and we
also use a number of different Python
scripts to extract features from full
data and from structured and
unstructured data sets and then we we
also use psychic learn and pandas
unsurprisingly fairly heavily it just
lends itself quite well to feature
engineering and and classification
problems we build up training sets as
well I'm using crowd-sourced inand pre
labeled data and I'll talk wit about
this now so we I should have said
earlier we have about 140 different
sector types and about 40 different
product types three or four different
client types in about a dozen different
sales processes so invariably this means
we have to build up a fairly large
training set to actually come up with a
decent sample to train our models on so
we use a few different techniques to
build our training sets we have employed
kind of expert panels in the past to
classify large numbers of companies also
from a sector point of view it's quite
easy to find some businesses that are
pre classified so you can imagine a lot
of public companies on the stock
exchange are already pre classified I
mean everyone knows what what Vodafone
does or what BTW does so it's actually
quite easy to find some pre labeled data
prosectors anyway and then we can also
use crowdsourcing as a way of building
our training sets and this is basically
we'll we'll set up a set of questions
that people have to follow so each
company's effectively a job for them and
they will need to classify that business
soap
go on google or wherever and try and
understand what the business does and
then classify it into one of X number of
categories obviously we need to put in
place some kind of qualification
questions around that to make sure we
get good results and we also use a
majority vote to try and increase the
likelihood of having correctly labeled
data so we look at the majority of five
so that's training sets in terms of
feature engineering as i said we look at
a number of different structured and
unstructured data sets so we look at new
sources and website data that clearly
has its own problems so when trying to
extract free text from HTML you'll have
problems with badly formed HTML or
obviously just trying to strip out HTML
and JavaScript and all that kind of
stuff is also necessary there are
various Python libraries for doing that
obviously things like beautiful soup and
lxml and a library called goose I think
which is used for article extraction
there are some Java libraries as well
like boiler pipe which is pretty good
and they all had their kind of pros and
cons really and depending on the context
in which you're trying to trying to
extract cleaned up data it depends on
which one you'll you'll go for I would
say we didn't have great results with
beautiful super tends to be extremely
resource hungry and tends to fall over
pretty regularly so I would favor
something like lxml and then obviously
once we kind of generated these features
where for a lot of our data sets we're
building bag-of-words type models so
we're tokenizing the data we're
calculating tf-idf weights some of them
are more structured data sets like
patents and filings we can generate
features in terms of the classification
of the patent for example or or other
things and then in terms of actually
modeling the data so this is a
classification problem a supervised
learning problem we've got labels
already so we use scikit-learn as i
mentioned purely because it just allows
us to iterate very quickly on the data
we can try different models out logistic
regression
you know SVM's all that kind of stuff
all your stuff we actually opted for
linear SVM's just because linear models
are fast we've got thousands of features
it works for us and also we found pandas
tends to work quite well here because we
can combine different feature sets quite
rapidly and they work quite well with
scikit-learn so yeah so we have
typically thousands of features so this
is an example scikit-learn is quite nice
in that we can kind of examine some of
the feature weights that have been
learnt so I picked out for two sectors
here so computer networking and fashion
and I mean this is just illustrative but
the kind of features in the bag words
model that are coming out switches fiber
hosting you know the sort of thing you
would expect basically so the bars here
are basically their feature weights and
for fashion again you've got things like
clothing fashion accessories Bridal
nylon hats so again the sorts features
you'd expect to see which is which is
good so in summary on that element of it
we use multiple data sets as our input
and we find that allows us to get a
better quality result we build multi
classification logic class classifiers
for sector type product type client
typing sales process and we then apply
these classifiers to the three million
companies in our system to come up with
a set of label data from which we can
work and that really brings me on to the
actual problem at hand that about then
trying to understand the nature of the
digital economy so I should carry out
this with a few some of the challenges
we have in some of the assumptions we
have to make so I've said we look at
three million companies what we don't
look at our sole traders so there are a
lot of song traders out there you know
one man in his dog type businesses so
the IT consultant at home for example
isn't necessarily going to be counted
here because we can only track what we
what we can start from what we have a
hand
on some of the other challenges we face
around actually identify where these
businesses are so when a business
registers at companies house they'll
provide an address as to where they're
registered that isn't necessarily always
actually where they're trading or where
their place of businesses so it could be
the CEOs address it could be their
solicitors address for small businesses
anyway so that poses some challenges we
have some ways of dealing with these but
it can pose some issues one of the other
challenges is actually around trying to
understand the group structure of
businesses so unfortunately just
counting up all of the businesses in the
UK and saying yeah there we go there's
you know 2 million businesses that are
digital probably isn't going to work
because businesses are fairly complex
entities they'll own other businesses
and have subsidiaries have parents
before and owned potentially have
special purpose vehicles that have been
used for investment purposes and there
are temporary entities so it's actually
quite complicated trying to unpick the
structure of a business so again we've
done some things to deal with this but
it's not a solved problem I would say
and lastly i think the other other point
is counting businesses one way of
looking at the digital economy but
obviously another important measure is
trying to understand how many people are
employed in the digital economy I'm
trying to come up with an estimate of
how many employees there again has its
challenges if you're relying again on
company sales data then you're going to
be limited because you can only sample
not all businesses basically will be
reporting their employee numbers so it's
hard to get a handle on that so what did
we do so first of all we tried to build
a benchmarking sample from which we
could start so we wanted to start by
really trying to compare against the
existing definitions si si codes so the
goal of this stage is to try and build
this benchmarking sample so we only
included businesses where we had both si
si data and growth intelligence
classification data which means when I
said at the start twenty percent of
businesses
have si si codes that actually means we
immediately excluded them in this
element of the work what we then did was
to go through a process of cleaning up
these businesses so we we only really
were interested in active businesses so
we we drop businesses that aren't
trading the adornment so when a business
is dormant it basically means they
haven't filed any or traded for the last
year so they haven't failed any turnover
we drop dissolved businesses and also
those going into administration so those
winding up we also dropped holding
companies so those are potentially shell
companies or companies exist therefore
kind of accounting purposes for example
or umbrella companies that have millions
of sub subsidiaries and then we tried to
deal with this issue of group structure
as I mentioned so we clustered
businesses based on similarity of
company name some ownership information
some postcode information so we were
trying to find company groups basically
as I said that's an approach it's
there's more we could do here I think
but then once we'd group these clusters
of companies we then only pick the
highest reporting revenue entity I try
and find the main reporting legal entity
that left us with a benchmarking sample
of about 1.8 million companies from
which we could compare si si in and
growth intelligence classifications so
we then went on to try and identify
these digital companies so we made use
of our our sector and product type
classifications primarily and really
again as I said at the start the
intuition behind this is to try and find
digital businesses that are in digital
sectors but also producing what you
might regard as digital things so first
step was just to come up with a short
list of these sectors and product
categories and then clean out any any
combinations that didn't make sense so
architecture firms you know building web
hosting or something probably doesn't
make sense so any kind of sparse
categories or ones that weren't made
sense were cleaned out and then we
simply yeah counted them up and we
divided them up into jog fries and
things and I'll show you some of those
results in a second and as I said the
real aim was to try and include
companies that are either digital
producers so for example the
architecture firm that produces CAD
software but exclude those that are
firms that aren't really you know term
digital in a sense that their input or
output vertical isn't associated with it
so these are our results so we the top
two rows there are using the standard
Industrial Classification measurement so
about ten percent of businesses using
standard measurements are are deemed
digital economy businesses using our
measurements we found 14 point four
percent so an increase of about forty
four percent there were deemed digital
and and i should say this is probably
our most conservative estimate because
as i said we haven't included businesses
that are classified as well don't have a
classification don't have an SOC
classification so that's twenty percent
already and we also have been quite
restrictive in terms of the sector
product categorization so this was this
was very interesting and really it means
there are about 80,000 businesses that
haven't been accounted for that could be
Dean digital businesses so I'll give you
an example this is a company called
Kelton engineering they're based in
Aberdeen they're very the example I
hinted at earlier they are an oil and
gas company they produced software for
monitoring oil flows and they do some
software consultancy as well so are our
classification basically came out with
oil and energy for their sector computer
software for their product type
businesses is their client type and
projects is their sales process now
we're classified under the SOC system is
other so it's an anecdotal example but
it illustrates the point and when I had
to look at this one I thought is quite
nice that on the website the three key
things that they do software oil and gas
it was were basically on their own page
so it was quite quite interesting so I
mentioned we looked at where these
businesses were based so we looked at
travel to work areas and plotted them
and then we found unsurprisingly in
terms of raw counts of businesses the
majority can be found in in London and
then we also found there are large
numbers of business in in Manchester
Birmingham Bristol Brighton
Middlesbrough as well actually and the
great southeast what was more
interesting was when we looked at some
of the densities so we we tried to
account for local population density as
well so try to fight identify regions
where they had a higher than expected
number of digital businesses and so we
found again his areas like basingstoke
read in Newbury the kind of corridor
that you would expect but also places
like pull and Stevenage I suppose again
you'd expect to see bright Brighton and
Guildford on there Cambridge Oxford but
Middlesbrough again was quite an
interesting an interesting one that
cropped up so what's plotted here so
he's the location question so anything
above one which is basically where my
all of these bars are above one implies
a greater than average population
density of digital businesses so I've
just basically gone and had a look at
Guildford specifically so I run a query
and pulled out the data for Guilford so
the numbers here are the counts in
different sector product categories so
we've got products across the top
sectors down the side and as you'd
expect there's a lot of custom software
development financial services
consultancy I suppose IT consultancy and
anyone who knows Guilford also knows
there's quite a strong computer gaming
industry there so that they were also
picked up computer games in desktop
so I mentioned we had some additional
work we did we had some additional
findings we looked at the some other
descriptors about these businesses so we
looked at the revenue and revenue growth
of these businesses we actually found
digital businesses tended to be faster
growing then than traditional businesses
and we also looked at employee levels so
both of these I should caveat as I said
this depends we only had a limited
sample of data to work with here but
again we found that digital businesses
using our definitions had a higher
number of average employees then a
non-traditional so in terms of further
work as I said we're we're on going here
the next phase is really to try and
understand the drivers and behind
innovate innovation and growth of these
businesses and to provide more
descriptive analysis of these businesses
so we we tag businesses as well with
with basically technologies industry
terms people organizations so we have a
very rich set of tags that we can
associate with companies and we want to
use that to help into more detail around
what it means to be digital we can also
do a few other things we we may choose
to do a kind of unsupervised clustering
approach to just kind of validate I
suppose the kinds of classifications
that we've come up with and validate
whether that makes any sense the UK is
planning on releasing more data that
data and more data on businesses out
there which might make it easier for us
to actually extend this to looking at
sole traders and and lastly we want to
we want to look in Europe and we want to
look try and apply this approach to
France and Germany and Belgium Italy and
just try and understand the kind of dish
will make up a business there and then
you know to compare countries really so
so that's it for me i should say as i
said we've got a number of challenges
and i suppose i'm allowed one maybe plug
we're hiring so if you want to come and
chat to me about working on solving
these problems feel free but otherwise
if you have any question
yeah I'm open to questions